the terror of the empire the seeds of
rebellion the andor trailer has
something for every star wars fan
considering that andorra is set before
the events of rogue one a star wars
story it was likely we would spot some
familiar faces of those who perished in
the film after all one of them literally
has his name as the show's title but
besides the show casting a spotlight on
cassian andor's road to rebellion a
critical figure in the fight against the
empire is saw guerrera who returns once
again played by oscar winner forrest
whitaker the one-time guardian of jyn
erso is shown here and talks with luther
potentially on jedha long before it was
destroyed he's displaying his more
direct approach to handling the empire
with a new ally let's call it war even
the question worth asking is how much
he'll be in the new series in rogue one
guerrera captures cassian while with jyn
right before jedha is destroyed however
when the two briefly meet guerrero
refrains from attacking the rebel who
rushes jinn to safety save the dream
with this in mind could this prequel to
the prequel show guerrera have a passing
encounter with andor but not enough to
mess up the already galaxy-sized
continuity of the star wars universe
might we also see guerrera carrying
fewer battle scars than in rogue one
where he was becoming more machine than
man
everything is connected in the star wars
universe so it was no surprise to get an
homage of sorts to rogue one a star wars
story in the second and or trailer at
one point we see what looks like a young
andor climbing into the mysterious
imperial ship that has landed on his
planet the entrance to the vessel is a
long dark corridor which makes andor
look relatively small and insignificant
by comparison rogue one fans might have
recognized this perspective on a young
character as it's similar to one from
the 2016 film when a young jyn erso
hides from orson krennic in the film's
opening scene she's likewise shown in a
tunnel at a distance just after her
mother is killed and her father is taken
captive by the empire jen hides in an
underground shelter saw guerrera finds
her and we see the same perspective of
looking down a long shaft toward our
future hero considering that andor is a
direct spin-off of rogue one there are
likely to be more homages to the film
a star wars television series about a
fermenting rebellion would not be
complete without an imperial antagonist
although there is very little known
about the imperial officer that actor
denise guff will be playing the trailer
makes clear that she is integral in the
empire's early attempts at quashing the
rebellion considering that andor takes
place before the events of rogue one a
star wars story the rebellion is not yet
strong enough to even contemplate
launching large-scale attacks on the
empire the trailer for andorra has
several shots featuring guff's character
so it's safe to assume that she will be
an imposing foil for cassian andor the
first scene shows her flanked by two
intimidating imperial death troopers
while the next sees her walking in a
sterile looking hallway while a
voiceover explains that someone's caught
in her net another moment has her
lording over a holographic map she then
asks are you a fish are you a thief
guff's character who is rigid and
orderly looks to be the opposite of
andor a cunning trickster who is always
thinking on his feet it will be
interesting to see how this as yet
unknown character fits in the greater
lore of the star wars universe
at one point in the trailer there are a
few shots of ruined ships being ripped
to shreds in some kind of junkyard
smaller ships and workers cut into them
presumably to salvage these destroyed
ships parts this imagery will look
awfully familiar to anyone who's played
star wars jedi fallen order which kicks
off with troubled padawan calcestus
hiding out as a worker on the junk
planet braca he's just one of the
thousands working on the planet to
dismantle republic-era ships fighters
and droids to make some money in the
andorr trailer cassian is surrounded by
scrappers and junk implying that he
might be on bronca or a planet like it
as part of a mission against the empire
this doesn't necessarily mean we'll get
a direct link to fallen order even
though fans of the game would probably
love to see one but it's worth noting
that the new series takes place in a
similar time frame to fall in order it
remains to be seen if this is just
something similar to the game or an
actual location from it the andor
trailer also features a blink and you'll
miss it appearance from an incomparable
fan favorite star wars icon ben thicke
two tubes the alien who briefly appears
in solo and rogue one is back for more
shady shenanigans in the new series
in the new trailer benthic stands guard
in a canyon setting with a black and
gray x-wing in the background in case it
wasn't clear two tubes gets his name
because of his breathing apparatus
tognaths don't normally breathe oxygen
so he needs it for oxygen atmospheres
the mercenary is a skilled fighter and
he first shows up chronologically in
solo working alongside emphasis nest and
the cloud riders we're not marauders
we're allies
benthick later joined saw guerrera and
his extremist group the partisans
because he wants to actively fight the
empire he appears in rogue one on the
planet jedha but why doesn't benthic
join the rebel alliance well mon
mothma's organization didn't approve of
guerrera's violent tactics so they're
not welcome in the central rebellion
hopefully the mercenary will get to do
more in andor than he did in solo and
rogue one andorra hits disney plus
september 21st 2022
you